what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
today the article for empire magazine
officially came out the one that we've
been talking about for about a week now
and with that new article comes four
brand new photos for spider-man no way
home and a little bit of information
about the movie now it's nothing really
really big however toby mcguire and
andrew garfield's names are in the
article and they are teased so much like
the other days of this week lots of
spider-man news today and i'm going to
break it all down and of course if you
love spider-man and the mcu be sure to
subscribe and hit the notification bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos and so you can enter to
win a spider-man bring varian arts
action figure it's super cool and all
you gotta do to enter subscribe to my
channel and subscribe to my other
channel cosmic culture leave some
comments on some videos so let's sort of
walk through these photos one by one
before we dive into some things that the
article says because i know the photos
are what everybody enjoys and let's
start with this one of doc ock because i
truly think that it is the most
interesting for a few reasons here one a
photo was released yesterday where doc
ock was holding up spider-man now
yesterday he only had two arms holding
him up one was wrapped around him and
the other was holding his head now this
is probably the same scene the
background is a little bit different it
looks like they could be under the
bridge instead of on top of the bridge
but we do see a car webbed up to the
right of alfred molina's doc ock now
we've obviously seen the photo of doc
ock throwing the cars and as i predicted
spider-man was probably running to try
and save some of the cars by webbing
them up and making sure that they don't
fall off the bridge it looks like he was
pretty successful in that part however
it looks like he has his work cut out
for him with doc ock and i've actually
been told something kind of specific
about this photo if you look closely to
his arms you can actually see that he
has some red in his arms now what i've
been told from a source is that these
are actually nanobots and it looks like
they could be from tom holland's nano
technology iron spider suit now that's
all of the information that i could get
unfortunately but if you do take a look
closely they do kind of look like it
could be from tom holland's nano suit so
now a few questions arise because of
this one why two who exactly did this
now the article mentions that they are
bringing villains over from the sam remy
universe obviously doc ock is confirmed
as we're getting all of these pictures
and saw him in the trailer however just
because he's from the raimi universe
doesn't exactly mean it's the exact same
doc ock from spider-man 2. perhaps he
comes from a timeline where he actually
defeated tobey maguire spider-man and he
lived and he went on and perhaps he
could have developed some nano
technology himself in fact i actually
think it would be pretty dang cool if
his arms were nanotech so could this be
something that doc awk is doing he does
look like he is fully in control with
the red nanotech on his tentacles but it
could also be something that spider-man
tried to do did he try to deploy some of
his suit on doc ock to try and fight him
could he have tried to put his own
nanotech on his tentacles to try and
control the arms because i can
definitely see how that could be a
tactic however judging by this photo i
don't think it's really working i think
if anything it probably gives gog a
little bit more strength and who knows
we know that peter is going to go
through a few different suits in
spider-man no way home perhaps doc ock
actually takes the nanotech from his
suit and puts them on his tentacles we
have no idea what type of technology doc
ock is going to have when he comes into
spider-man no way home but perhaps it
could be pretty advanced and i actually
think this would be a cool initial
encounter doc got kind of just
completely overpowering spider-man to
where he needs some help aka the other
two spider-man now another picture that
we have is of spider-man and it appears
that he is in the basement of the new
york sanctum three things about this
photo that i noticed one is that there
seems to be sort of two parts to this
basement one part behind him looks like
it has furniture it looks like it's kind
of a lounge area and the part in front
of him where he's standing kind of looks
like it's all made out of rock it
actually looks like the place where
doctor strange does the spell that's the
second thing i noticed but peter parker
is in his spider-man suit here and when
we saw him in the trailer he was not in
a spider-man suit when doctor strange
did the spell this leads me to believe
that this is going to be after he does
the spell and perhaps the villains could
have broken out of the prison right here
this could be after spider-man and
doctor strange fight because as rumor
has it right now doctor strange and
peter fight and that's what releases the
villains now the last thing i noticed is
the staircase in the background that
staircase is actually where peter mj and
ned were when we got our very first
photo for spider-man no way home of the
three of them looking up at a mysterious
figure this looks like the exact same
place so the mysterious figure could be
doctor strange however at this point in
time peter probably ran into him already
so could it actually be another
spider-man coming from a different
universe that's something i'm very
curious to see because they want us to
believe that they're looking at doctor
strange and typically when marvel wants
us to believe something it's because
it's something else but we'll have to
wait and see until the movie comes out
now there's two more photos and there's
not really that much to them to look
into one is of doctor strange he's
standing there with his arms crossed he
has a sling ring in his hand and he has
a cut on the side of his face we can
maybe assume that him and peter just got
done fighting and the villains broke out
and possibly that scratch came from
peter or one of the villains again it's
just a picture of him in front of the
sanctum with his arms crossed which
means he's probably pretty upset about
something so i'm gonna go ahead and say
this is after the fight and after the
villains get out but again it's just a
picture of him standing there so it's
really hard to tell and for the last
photo we've kind of seen this before and
we know the context of the situation
this is pretty much right after the
events of spider-man far from home's
post credit scene mj is with peter and
they're very very high it looks like
they were on top of some type of
scaffolding or really big construction
equipment it looks like peter grabbed
him jay and kind of took off a little
bit but then the helicopter starts
surrounding them he's wearing the exact
same suit that he was in the post
credits so far from home and so is mj
she's wearing the exact same clothes so
we pretty much know exactly what the
scene is now like i did mention empire
magazine did talk a little bit about
tobey maguire and andrew garfield of
course they did not confirm anything
they're not going to confirm something
that big in an empire magazine article
but i'll tell you what they said now
first off they did kind of address other
rumors like jamie foxx returning as
elektro and of course sandman and the
lizard returning as well but all they
really said was these are rumors going
around well yeah no kidding their rumors
going around and just saying that their
rumors is not confirming or denying so
it's a great response but it doesn't
tell us anything at all but then they go
and talk about other rumors like kristen
dunst possibly returning emma stone
possibly returning and then they give us
this paragraph and most seismically
there have been reports that holland
won't be the only spider-man in the
movie that at some point the current
peter parker will share a screen with
toby maguire and andrew garfield the
actors who preceded him in the role we
could be looking at a veritable peck of
peter parker's spider-man's spider-man's
doing whatever spiders can it goes on to
say the way in which these rumors have
blossomed and mutated has been
fascinating to watch going from mere
wishful thinking to being treated as
cold hard fact in record time there is
now an expectation among spider fans
that garfield and maguire will show up
at some point in no way home and listen
to what kevin foggy says about this
rumors are fun because many of them are
true and many of them are not true the
danger is when you get into the
expectations game of wanting people to
be excited about the movie they get and
not disappointed by a movie they didn't
get to me kevin feige is playing it cool
i mean it's kevin foggy he's the
ultimate cool guy but at this point in
time i've seen enough evidence for
myself and have talked to enough
insiders who have confirmed that both
toby and andrew are in the film that i
fully believe that they are coming in
fact i've been told some pretty specific
details about some scenes that
unfortunately i can't reveal but i love
how kevin feige said rumors are fun
because many of them are true and the
best part about this article is that
again i mentioned before in the past
sony and marvel studios have to sign off
on what they publish they have to agree
to let them publish everything in this
article so they read it all entirely
before it goes out and if there's
something in there that they don't like
they say cut this part so they let them
put all of that stuff in there about
andrew garfield about tobey maguire
kirsten dunst which is to me just
another sign that they are in the film
because they're not going to let them
talk about it and get everybody's
expectations up just for them to not be
in the movie but let me know what you
think about these new photos and about
this article in the comments down below
you